kumusta ang pangalan ko ay Olivia Lanes at maligayang pagbabalik sa Quantum Computing sa Praktika ito ay episode dalawa Quantum
circuits tatalakayin natin ang ilang paksa sa lektura ngayon ngunit ang gusto kong mauwi mo ay ang tatlong bagay na ito una kung ano talaga ang IBM
quantum computers para magkaroon ka man lang ng magaspang na larawan sa isip mo kung ano ang ginagawa mo kapag nagpadala ka ng trabaho sa isa sa mga ito sa
cloud dalawa kung ano ang qubit kung ano ang mga Primitive at kung paano natin magagamit ang mga ito para lumikha at mag-execute ng Quantum circuits
tatalakayin din natin sa mataas na antas ang iba't ibang uri ng IBM Quantum processors na available at kung ano ang nagtatangi sa isa mula sa isa pa at tatlo
sa wakas ang tipikal na workflow na sinusundan natin para magpatakbo ng mga eksperimento sa malaking sukat kasama dito ang pagpili ng pinakamahusay na mga Primitive
para sa iyong use case ang pag-map ng isang problema sa isang Quantum circuit at ang pag-apply ng error suppression at mitigation na nagbibigay-daan
sa atin na mapakinabangan ang pinakamaraming kapangyarihan mula sa mga makina na ito ngayon marami itong impormasyon ngunit sumama sa akin
dahil sa lalong madaling panahon ilalagay natin ang lahat ng ito nang magkasama sa konteksto ng ilang tunay na halimbawa una nating pag-usapan nang maikli ang mga qubit at ang aktwal na Quantum
Hardware bilang isang eksperimentalista maaari ko itong ipangako sa iyo na ito ay kahali-halina at nakakatulong talaga na maisalarawan ang mga tuldok para
mailarawan kung ano talaga ang nangyayari kapag ang mga trabaho ay isinumite sa isang quantum computer sa pamamagitan ng cloud ang mga processor na
gagamitin natin ay ginawa gamit ang superconducting transmon qubits narito ang hitsura ng isang maliit na IBM quantum processor
ngayon ang maliliit na parisukat na ito ay ang mga qubit mismo kaya mayroon kaming kabuuang lima sa chip na ito ang transmon
mismo ay isang capacitor at binubuo ito ng dalawang plato ng metal na konektado nang magkasamang may isang nonlinear na inductor na tinatawag na
Josephson junction ngunit para makita ang Josephson junction kailangan mo talagang mag-zoom in pa mas malapit ito ay nilikha mula sa dalawang
magkapatong na layer ng superconducting metal at kung saan ang dalawang piraso ay nagtatagpo at nagtatagpo ang junction ay isang Josephson
Junction ay isang elemento na maaaring gamitin para lumikha ng isang artipisyal na atom na may maraming antas ng enerhiya at inihihiwalay natin
ang dalawang pinakamababang antas ng enerhiya bilang ating Qubit State ang mga squiggly na linya dito ay kumakatawan sa mga microwave resonator
karaniwang 2D transmission lines na nakakonekta sa qubit ngayon kapag nag-program tayo ng gate iyon ay katumbas ng pagpili ng isang
lubhang calibrated na microwave pulse at ang tiyak na frequency amplitude hugis at tagal ng mga pulse na iyon ang nagpapatakbo sa
qubit para gumawa ng mga tiyak na bagay ang mga instruksyon para sa microwave pulse ay galing sa iyong computer papunta sa cloud at
pagkatapos ay binabasa at isinasalin ng room temperature control Electronics na kumukuha ng mga instruksyon na iyon at pisikal na
nagge-generate ng mga pulse tinatawag natin itong microwave pulses dahil lahat sila ay akma sa loob ng microwave frequency bandwidth
na nasa paligid ng 1 GHz pagkatapos likhain ng room temperature control boxes ang mga pulse naglalakbay sila sa mga cable
papunta sa dilution refrigerator at sa kalaunan ay sa ating Quantum chip ang signal ay pumapasok sa mga resonator sa pamamagitan ng
isang wire bond sa mga pad na ito at pagkatapos ay dumadaloy sa linya ng transmission papunta sa ating mga qubit ngayon alam ko na maaaring lahat ng ito
ay medyo teknikal at ang mga detalyeng ito ay hindi krusyal na maunawaan para sa atin sa pagsulong ngunit umaasa akong ngayon
ay maaari kayong lahat man lang mailarawan ang pisikal na sistema na lahat kayo ay malapit nang makipag-ugnayan kaya saan talaga mayroon ang mga quantum computer
mabuti ang IBM ay may dose-dosenang mga quantum computer sa buong mundo at kamakailan ay na-upgrade namin ang aming Fleet para
maglaman lamang ng 100 plus na Qubit processors tulad ng nasabi ko sa nakaraang aralin ang ilan sa kanila ay matatagpuan sa isang IBM
Quantum data center sa Upstate New York ang mga sistemang iyon ay naka-deploy sa buong cloud para sa paggamit ng lahat at ang ilan sa
kanila ay mga dedicated on premise na sistema na kumpleto sa lahat ng electronics para mapapatakbo ang mga ito na sumusuporta sa ating mga kasosyo
sa IBM quantum network ngayon pag-usapan natin ang Qiskit na siyang open-source software development kit ng IBM
na idinisenyo para gumana sa mga quantum computer mula ngayon ay irerefer ko ito bilang ang Qiskit SDK mayroon din ang Qiskit
ecosystem na isang koleksyon ng software tutorials at mga function na nagtatayo o nagpapalawak ng mga pangunahing functionality ng Qiskit pati na rin ang Qiskit
runtime na isang Quantum Computing service at programming model na nagbibigay-daan sa mga user na mag-disenyo at mahusay na
mag-execute ng kanilang Quantum workloads sa pamamagitan ng paggamit ng Qiskit Primitives at ang isang Primitive ay karaniwang isang maliit na building block na
maaari mong gamitin para mag-disenyo ng mas malalaking circuits o isang trabaho ang dalawang Primitive na pinakamahalaga sa atin ay magiging ang
sampler at ang estimator na tatalakayin natin nang mas malalim sa lalong madaling panahon kung hindi ka pa nag-download at nag-install ng
Qiskit SDK wala nang mas magandang oras kaysa ngayon ang Qiskit 1.0 ay kamakailan lamang na inilabas at ito ay mas performative at
matatag kaysa kailanman kaya para sa inyo na nagsisimula pa lamang dumating ka sa perpektong oras para sa inyo
na pamilyar na sa Qiskit kakailanganin mong mag-download at muling mag-install ng pinakabagong bersyon inirerekomenda namin ang paggamit ng
pip para i-install ang Qiskit at ang Qiskit runtime at patakbuhin ang mga ito sa pamamagitan ng isang Jupyter notebook sa isang web browser po ang iyong pagpipilian kaya kakailanganin mo rin
na i-install ang jupyter notebook o Jupyter lab kung hindi mo pa nagagawa ang mga kasangkapan na ito ay lahat libre at
maaari mong i-set up at patakbuhin ang mga ito sa iyong sariling lokal na makina nang walang anumang gastos siguraduhing idagdag ang Qiskit na may visualization
option dependencies para gumana ito sa Jupyter at hayaan kang mag-plot ng mga bagay kakailanganin mo rin na mag-set up ng virtual python environment at mayroon
mga instruksyon kung paano ito gawin sa pahina ng pag-install ng Qiskit na naka-link dito kapag naging pamilyar ka na sa Qiskit at
handa ka nang magpatakbo ng mga trabaho sa tunay na quantum computers kakailanganin mong mag-rehistro sa quantum.com at lumikha ng isang IBM Quantum
API token at mayroon ding isang link dito para doon isang detalyadong walkthrough kung paano ito gawin sundin ang lahat ng
mga instruksyon sa aming pahina ng dokumentasyon tulad ng nabanggit ko o maaari kang manood ng coding with Qiskit installation video dito
ang parehong naka-link at nasa description ngayon ay halos handa na tayo para magsimulang pag-usapan ang Quantum
circuits dahil ang punto ng kursong ito ay turuan kayo ang madla kung paano mag-scale up ng iyong mga trabaho para patakbuhin sa 100 plus
Cubit na sukat naniniwala akong ang pinaka-konstruktibong paraan ay ang Una ay isaalang-alang ang pangkalahatang workflow na susundan natin at ang pinakamadaling paraan para
maunawaan ang isang tipikal na Quantum Computing workflow ay sa pamamagitan ng Qiskit patterns ang Qiskit patterns ay isang conceptual framework na nagbibigay-daan sa mga user na magpatakbo ng Quantum
workloads sa pamamagitan ng pagsasagawa ng ilang mga hakbang gamit ang modular tooling nagbibigay-daan ito sa mga gawain sa Quantum Computing na maisagawa ng
makapangyarihang heterogeneous Computing infrastructure ang mga hakbang na ito ay maaaring isagawa bilang isang serbisyo at maaari
mag-incorporate ng Resource Management na nagbibigay-daan para sa maayos na composability ng mga bagong kakayahan habang ang mga ito ay ginagawa dito
ay ang mga pangunahing hakbang na malamang ay makikilala na ng mga nakaranasang Qiskit user ang unang hakbang ay ang mapping ang hakbang na ito
ay nagpopormal kung paano natin kinukuha ang isang pangkalahatang problema na interesado tayo at nalalaman kung paano ito i-map sa isang quantum computer
sa anyo ng isang circuit susunod ay ina-optimize natin sa hakbang na ito ginagamit natin ang Qiskit transpiler para i-route at ilagay ang
circuit sa aktwal na pisikal na Quantum Hardware kasama dito ang pagsasalin ng mga indibidwal na Quantum Gates sa mga pagkakasunod-sunod
ng mga operasyong isinasagawa sa hardware pati na rin ang optimization sa layout ng mga gate na iyon susunod ay
ie-execute natin ang mga Qiskit runtime Primitive ay nagbibigay ng interface sa IBM Quantum Hardware na nagbibigay-daan sa transpiled circuit na tumakbo
kasama rin sa hakbang na ito ang paggamit ng mga teknik ng error suppression at mitigation na karaniwang maaaring abstract mula sa user sa wakas ay ginagawa natin ang postprocessing sa
hakbang na ito ang data mula sa quantum processor mismo ay pinoproseso na nagbibigay sa user ng mga kapaki-pakinabang na resulta sa orihinal na problema ang hakbang na ito
ay sumasaklaw sa anumang karagdagang pagsusuri ng data na nakuha ngayon ay handa na tating talakayin ang pundasyon ng quantum
programs na siyang quantum circuits umaasa ako na pamilyar ka na sa Quantum circuits ngunit kung hindi pa puwede mong suriin muna ang aralin
tatlo Quantum circuits na bahagi ng pag-unawa sa Quantum information at computation na naka-link sa ibaba
magbibigay lang tayo ng maikling refresher dito ngayon ang isang Quantum circuit ay isang network ng mga quantum Gates at measurements na naka-link
ng mga wire na kumakatawan sa mga qubit maaaring basahin ang Quantum circuits tulad ng sheet music mula kaliwa hanggang kanan simula sa
Time Zero na nasa kaliwa ng lahat virtual qubits ang ibig sabihin ay mga qubit na hindi pa itinalaga sa isang aktwal na
pisikal na qubit sa isang processor ay nakalista sa pataas na pagkakasunod mula itaas pababa kapag na-set up na natin ang ating circuit maaari tayong magdagdag
ng mga gate dito single qubit gates tulad ng Hadamard gate na ito ay nakakaapekto lamang sa qubit kung saan nakalagay ang wire nito multiple qubit
gates tulad ng cnot na ito ay nakakaapekto sa dalawa o higit pang mga qubit na naka-link ng gate dito sa halimbawang ito ang estado ng qubit one ay nagbabago
depende sa kung ano ang estado ng qubit zero ay pagkatapos mailapat ang lahat ng mga gate maaari tayong magsagawa ng mga measurement
na nagiging sanhi ng pagsulat ng mga resulta sa mga classical register isa sa partikular na mahalagang katangian ng
isang circuit ay ang lalim nito ang lalim ng quantum circuit ay ang pinakamababang bilang ng mga layer ng mga quantum Gates na ine-execute nang
sabay-sabay na kinakailangan para makumpleto ang computation na tinukoy ng circuit upang maging malinaw ang mga Quantum Gates ay maaaring i-execute nang
sabay-sabay o sa ibang salita sa eksaktong parehong oras tuwing wala silang anumang mga qubit na magkasamang ngunit kung dalawa o higit pang
mga gate ay kumikilos sa parehong mga qubit hindi natin sila maisasagawa nang sabay-sabay napipilitan tayong isagawa ang mga ito nang isa-isa dahil ang mga Quantum Gates ay nangangailangan ng oras para
maipatupad ang lalim ng isang circuit ay halos tumutugma sa dami ng oras na kailangan ng mga quantum computer para i-execute ang
circuit kaya ang pag-alam ng lalim ng isang circuit ay mahalaga para malaman na maaari itong gamitin para patakbuhin sa isang partikular na device o hindi at sasabihin din nito sa atin kung ito
ay may magandang pagkakataon ng pagiging tumpak na resulta susunod ay lumipat tayo sa pagpili ng isang Quantum processor ang IBM
ay kamakailan ay naglabas ng isang buong bagong Fleet ng mga processor na lahat ay may mahigit 100 qubit at maaari kang mag-log on sa quantum.com para makita
kung aling mga processor ang maa-access mo ang mga processor ay lahat ay pinangalanan pagkatapos ng mga ibon para sa mga dahilan at ang iba't ibang mga logo
ay kumakatawan sa iba't ibang uri ng mga processor halimbawa ang mga ito ay kumakatawan sa mga Eagle processor at ang icon na ito ay isang
heron ang pangalan ng mga tiyak na processor ay matatagpuan din sa itaas lahat sila ay pinangalanan pagkatapos ng mga lungsod ngunit iyon
ay hindi nangangahulugang ang processor ay pisikal na matatagpuan sa lungsod na iyon ang mga iyon ay mga pangalan lamang ang bilang ng qubit
eppg at clops ay mga salik din na nakalista lahat tatalakayin natin ang bawat isa sa mga ito
mga qubit ngayon ito ay medyo self-explanatory ang qubits ay ang bilang lamang ng kabuuang mga qubit na available para gamitin sa solong Quantum processor o
qpu ang EPG ay nangangahulugang mga error bawat layered gate na sumusukat sa average na gate process error sa isang layered chain ng
100 qubits karaniwang gusto mong maging kasing liit ng posible ang clops ay nangangahulugang circuit layer operations per second at
sumusukat kung gaano karaming mga layer ng isang Quantum volume circuit na siyang isang virtual circuit ang maaaring i-execute ng isang qpu bawat unit ng oras
mas mataas ang numero mas mabilis tayong makakacompute ito ay katumbas ng ibig sabihin ng flops sa classical Computing ngayon ang mga
iba't ibang metrics na ito ay maaaring mas o hindi gaanong mahalaga depende sa tiyak na application area na interesado ka susunod ay talakayin natin sa mataas na antas
ang pag-map sa Quantum circuits ang unang hakbang ay ang mapping step na mahalagang sumasagot sa tanong kung paano ko
isasalin ang aking problema sa isang Quantum circuit na maaaring patakbuhin sa Quantum Hardware ngayon walang duda tungkol dito
ang mapping ay isang mahirap na problema at ito ay isang aktibong lugar ng pananaliksik minsan ang simpleng kakayahang kumuha ng isang computational
problema at makakuha ng isang pagkakasunod-sunod ng mga quantum Gates na nakakatulong sa paglutas nito ang pinakamahirap na bahagi wala itong napatunayang pamamaraan
na ginagarantiyahan ang tagumpay ngunit mayroon mga inirerekomendang alituntunin at mga halimbawa ng mga problema na alam na natin kung paano
i-map ang unang alituntunin ay hayaan ang mga classical computer na gumawa ng anumang gawain na mas mahusay sila doon mismo mga pagsusulit
na madali para sa mga classical computer ay malamang na hindi makikinabang mula sa isang quantum computer ang mga quantum computer ay para sa mga problemang mahirap sa classical na
kaayusan kung ito ang iyong unang pagkakataon sa paggamit ng Qiskit o isang quantum computer huwag mag-alala tungkol sa paghanap ng isang problema na computationally complex basagin ito
sa mas maliliit na problema na maaari mong matutunan na matugunan bago pumunta nang diretso sa isang utility scale project susunod ay isalain ang
mga resulta para sa iyong problema na gusto mong sukatin o maunawaan sa isang expectation value problem o isang sampling
problema para sa karamihan ng uri ng mga problema ito ay mahalagang katumbas ng pagkalkula ng isang cost function ang isang cost function ay isang
problem specific function na nagtatukoy ng layunin ng problema bilang isang bagay na dapat i-minimize o i-maximize at maaari sila
gamitin para makita kung gaano kahusay ang isang trial state o solusyon ay gumaganap kaugnay sa layunin na iyon
ang notiong ito ay maaaring ilapat sa iba't ibang mga application sa chemistry machine learning Finance optimization at iba pa
gayundin tandaan na ang hardware na gagamitin mo ay may tiyak na topology ang ilang mga qubit ay hindi konektado
at ang ilan ay at sa huli kailangan mong i-map ang iyong problema sa isang circuit na kumakatawan dito ang mga IBM Quantum processor
ay gumagamit ng tinatawag na heavy hex topology na mahalagang katumbas ng mga Qubit Connections sa isang hexagonal lattice na
tatalakayin natin nang mas malalim sa ibang pagkakataon sa kurso sa ngayon ang pinakamahalagang bagay na dapat tandaan ay ang yugtong ito ay nangangailangan ng
pagsasanay kailangan mong magkaroon ng mabuting pag-unawa hindi lamang sa iyong problema kundi pati na rin sa Quantum Hardware
mga kakayahan at magdaraan tayo ng isang tiyak na halimbawa at use case sa ibang pagkakataon para makita kung paano ang mga ito ay pinakamahusay na
balansehin ngayon ay talakayin natin kung paano mag-optimize ng isang circuit para sa hardware na aming pinili ang pangkalahatang layunin ng
optimization step ay ang i-map ang lahat ng virtual qubits mula sa ating circuit sa mga aktwal na tunay na qubit kahit saan sa
topology ng processor ang laro ay ang bawasan ang mga error hangga't maaari para magawa ito kailangan muna nating
i-route at ilagay ang ating circuit nang mahusay ang unang bagay na dapat tandaan ay ang hindi lahat ng mga qubit ay konektado tulad ng
nasabi ko na ang ilan ay talagang malayo sa isa't isa sa chip kaya kailangan nating bawasan o alisin ang mga long-distance
na interaksyon tuwing posible maaari kang mag-apply ng isang pagkakasunod-sunod ng mga swap gate sa pagitan ng mga kalapit na qubit para ilipat ang Qubit
impormasyon ngunit ang mga swap gate ay mahal at madaling magkaroon ng error kaya maaaring may mas magagandang paraan ng paggawa nito susunod ang layout
at ang routing ay mga iterative na proseso at nag-aasign ng isang virtual qubit sa iyong circuit sa pisikal na qubit sa
hardware maaari mong gawin ito nang manu-mano ngunit mayroon ding mga tools sa Qiskit na maaaring gumawa ng mga rekomendasyon para sa pisikal na
qubit layout batay sa approximate na mga error rate susunod ay maaari tayong mag-compose ng mga pagkakasunod-sunod ng mga single qubit gates na kumikilos sa parehong qubit
sa mga single gates at maaari rin tayong minsan maalis ang mga hindi kinakailangang gate o mga kombinasyon ng mga gate halimbawa
ang ilang mga kombinasyon ng mga gate ay maaaring bawasan sa mas simpleng mga kombinasyon at minsan ang mga kombinasyon ng mga gate
ay katumbas ng isang simpleng identity operator kaya maaari nating alisin ang mga ito maaari mong gawin ito nang awtomatiko gamit ang
Qiskit transpiler o maaari mong gawin ito nang manu-mano sa isang gate bawat gate na batayan kung mayroon kang magandang dahilan para gawin ito at gusto mo
ng mas maraming kontrol kapag napabuti na natin ang circuit layout routing at mga bilang ng gate alinman sa pamamagitan ng kamay o sa pamamagitan ng paggamit ng Qiskit transpiler
kadalasan ay gusto nating mailarawan ang ating circuit para masiguro na ang timing ng lahat ng mga gate ay makatuwirang may argumento na maaari mong i-flag sa transpiler para
mailarawan ang timeline ng iyong circuit at matiyak na lahat ay nakahanay tulad ng iyong inaasahan ngayon pag-usapan natin ang error
suppression ang error suppression ay tumutukoy sa iba't ibang mga teknik na nagbabago ng isang circuit sa panahon ng compilation para mabawasan ang mga error
ito ay kakaiba mula sa error mitigation na nagaganap pagkatapos na patakbuhin na ang circuit at darating tayo doon sa lalong madaling panahon ang dalawang pinakakaraniwang anyo ng
error suppression na sinasamantala natin ay dynamical decoupling at Pauli twirling magkakaroon ng ilang
teknikal na detalye dito ngunit maaari kang palaging bumalik sa ito sa ibang pagkakataon kaya ang una ay ang dynamical decoupling na ginagamit para
epektibong kanselahin ang ilang ingay na nakakaapekto sa qubit sa pamamagitan ng pag-apply ng isang serye ng mga gate na magkasamang katumbas ng
identity operation tulad ng mga XX sequence na ang netong epekto ay approximate na kanselahin ang mga ingay na channel na nakakaapekto
sa qubit ang Pauli twirling ay isang paraan ng pagpasok ng mga random na gate para pasimplehin ang average na ingay ang randomness ay nakakatulong
na pigilan ang mga epekto mula sa iba't ibang mga error na mabilis na umusbong at ginagawa rin nitong mas madaling i-characterize ang ingay
ngayon ang pamamaraang ito ay nagtatakda rin ng batayan ng isang teknik ng error mitigation at tatalakayin natin iyon sa ibang pagkakataon
muli maraming impormasyon dito at huwag mag-alala kung hindi lahat ito ay nagsasawsaw agad sa kabutihang palad marami sa ito ay maaaring gawin nang awtomatiko gamit ang Qiskit
transpiler ang transpilation ay maaaring maging mapaghamong bagaman ngunit ang transpilation ay napakahalagan para makamit ang utility sa malaking sukat
na nangangailangan ng maraming pagsubok at pagkakamali para mapanamo at makuha ang pinakamahusay na mga resulta ngayon gusto kong kumuha ng maikling
interlude para talakayin ang Qiskit transpiler at ang mga kakayahan nito nang kaunti pa gagawin ko ito sa napakataas na antas at tatalakayin natin ang mga detalye at makita
ang ilang mga halimbawa sa ibang pagkakataon sa pangkalahatan ang transpilation ay ang proseso ng muling pagsulat ng isang ibinigay na input circuit para tumugma
sa topology at tiyak na Quantum device at i-optimize ang circuit para sa execution at katatagan laban sa ingay
binibigyang-kahulugan din nito ang isang ibinigay na circuit sa mga basis Gates ng tiyak na Quantum processor na pinili mong gamitin ang Qiskit ay may apat na
built-in transpilation pipelines at malibang pamilyar ka na sa Quantum circuit optimization talagang inirerekomenda ko ang paggamit ng isa sa mga iyon
built-in na pipelines bilang default kasama sa transpiler ang anim na hakbang na ito initialization
layout routing translation optimization at scheduling ngayon ang initialization ay tumutukoy sa
anumang initial pass na kinakailangan bago natin simulan ang pag-embed ng circuit sa backend karaniwan itong nagsasangkot ng
pag-unroll ng mga custom na instruksyon at pag-convert ng circuit sa isa at dalawang qubit gates ang layout stage ay nag-a-apply
ng isang layout na nag-ma-map ng mga virtual qubits sa circuit sa mga pisikal na qubit sa isang backend ang routing ay tumatakbo pagkatapos na ma-apply ang isang layout at
nag-i-inject ng mga gate tulad ng mga swap gate sa orihinal na circuit para gawing compatible ito sa connectivity ng backend
ang ikaapat na yugto ay translation sa yugtong ito ang mga gate sa circuit ay isinalin sa Target
backends basis set susunod ay ang optimization ang yugtong ito ay nagpapatakbo ng pangunahing optimization
loop nang paulit-ulit hanggang sa matugunan ang isang kondisyon tulad ng pagkamit ng isang tiyak na Target depth mayroon tayong apat na iba't ibang optimization
levels na maaari nating piliin ang huli ay ang scheduling ang yugtong ito ay para sa anumang hardware aware scheduling passes sa isang
mataas na antas ang scheduling ay maaaring isipin bilang pagpasok ng mga pagkaantala sa circuit para ipaliwanag ang anumang idle time sa mga qubit
sa pagitan ng execution ng mga instruksyon kaya tulad ng sinabi ko may apat na optimization levels mula 0 hanggang tatlo kung saan
mas mataas na optimization levels ay nangangailangan ng mas maraming oras at computational effort ngunit maaari kang makakuha ng mas mahusay na circuit
ang optimization level zero ay inilaan para sa mga eksperimento ng device characterization at tulad nito ay nag-ma-map lamang ng input circuit sa
mga hadlang ng target backend hindi ito nagsasagawa ng anumang optimization ang optimization level tatlo
ay gumagugol ng pinakamaraming pagsisikap para i-optimize ang circuit gayunpaman dahil marami sa mga teknik ng optimization sa
transpiler ay batay sa mga heuristics ang paggugol ng mas maraming computational effort ay hindi palaging nagreresulta sa isang pagpapabuti
sa kalidad ng output circuit kung interesado ka pa sa ito pakitingnan ang mga pahina ng transpiler sa Qiskit
dokumentasyon na naka-link sa ibaba ngayon ay handa na tayong talakayin ang aktwal na execution ng isang Quantum circuit
ang mga Qiskit runtime Primitive ay nagbibigay ng interface sa IBM Quantum hardware at i-a-abstract din nila ang error
suppression at mitigation mula sa user ang sampler primitive ay nagbabalik ng Quasi probability distribution o mga bilang
na kumakatawan sa posibilidad ng pagsusukat ng ilang bit strings na mga zero at isa ang estimator primitive ay nagbabalik ng expectation
values ng mga observable na katumbas ng mga pisikal na dami kaya sa kaunting detalye ang sampler ay nagpapatakbo ng circuit
nang maraming beses sa isang Quantum device na nagsasagawa ng mga measurement sa bawat pagpapatakbo at nagtatayo ng probability
distribution mula sa pagbawi ng mga bit string na iyon mas maraming pagpapatakbo o shots ang isasagawa mas tumpak ang mga resulta
ngunit nangangailangan ito ng mas maraming oras at ang Quantum Resources na kinakailangan para patakbuhin iyon specifically kinakalkula nito ang
posibilidad ng pagkuha ng bawat posibleng standard basis state sa pamamagitan ng pagsusukat ng estado na inihanda ng circuit ang Qiskit
estimator ay gumagamit ng kumplikadong algebraic na proseso para tantyahin ang expectation value sa isang tunay na Quantum device sa pamamagitan ng
pagbasag ng observable sa isang kombinasyon ng iba pang mga observable na may mga kilalang eigen bases at tumatakbo sa
ilalim ng kapote ng mga Primitive ay ang mga teknik na tinatawag na error mitigation ang error mitigation ay isang umbrella term para sa lahat ng ito at ito
ay mahalagang tumutukoy sa mga teknik na nagbibigay-daan sa atin na bawasan ang mga circuit error sa pamamagitan ng pag-model ng device noise sa oras ng
execution karaniwan ay nagdudulot ito ng Quantum pre-processing overhead na nauugnay sa model training at classical
post-processing overhead para mabawasan ang mga error sa mga raw na resulta sa pamamagitan ng paggamit ng isang generated model ngunit kapalit ng
overhead na ito ay nagagawa nating makakuha ng mas tumpak na mga resulta mayroon maraming mga teknik na maaari nating ipatupad para sa
error mitigation at tatalakayin natin ang tatlo sa mga ito nang mas detalyado ngunit alalahanin na ito ay isang lugar ng
aktibong pananaliksik kaya malamang ay may mga bagong teknik na maimbento at ang mga mas lumang teknik ay patuloy na mapabuti ang
resilience level ay nagpapataas ng gastos o sa ibang salita ang oras na kinakailangan para patakbuhin ang iyong trabaho sinabi na natin na sa
resilience level zero ang transpiler ay hindi talaga gumagawa ng anumang bagay sa iyong circuit ngunit simula sa resilience level isa ipinakilala nito ang isang pamamaraan na tinatawag na twirled
readout error extinction o tinatawag nating T-Rex para maikli ang twirled readout error extinction ay gumagamit ng Pauli twirling para
bawasan ang ingay na isang bagay na nabanggit na natin ito ay isang napaka-pangkalahatang at epektibong teknik na
sa simpleng pagsasalita ay ginagawang hindi gaanong irregular at mas madaling harapin ang ingay simula sa resilience level dalawa
ipinakilala natin ang zero noise extrapolation o zne para maikli ito ay isang popular na teknik na kamakailan ay nagkaroon tayo ng maraming
tagumpay ang ideya sa likod ng zne ay maaaring medyo nakagugulat talagang nagdadagdag tayo ng karagdagang
ingay sa ibabaw ng mayroon na ngunit ang ginagawa nito ay nagbibigay-daan sa atin na mag-extrapolate sa kabaligtaran na direksyon para
hulaan kung ano ang hitsura ng mga resulta kung mas kaunti ang ingay maaari itong gawin sa ilang tiyak na paraan halimbawa
maaari nating pahabain ang mga gate para gawing mas mahaba ang mga ito at sa gayon ay mas madaling magkaroon ng error o maaari tayong magpatakbo ng mas maraming gate na
nagresulta sa isang identity operation kaya ang circuit ay hindi talaga functional na nagbabago ngunit sinadya nating mag-sample ng mas maraming
ingay kailangan mong gawin ito para sa bawat circuit at bawat expectation value na gusto mong subaybayan kaya
makikita mo kung paano ito maaaring maging napakamahali sa mga tuntunin ng oras na kinakailangan ang isang tiyak na uri ng zne ay tinatawag na
probabilistic error amplification o pea para maikli kapag natutunan na natin ang isang noise model para sa isang gate ang pea ay gumagana sa pamamagitan ng pag-sample ng
mga error mula sa noise model na iyon at sadyang iniiniksyon ang mga ito sa circuit tulad ng nabanggit ko maraming bagong
mga teknik ang patuloy na ginagawa at sana ay ipapatupad habang mas marami pa ang dumarating mayroon pa lamang isang huling anyo ng
error mitigation na gusto kong talakayin na tinatawag na probabilistic error cancellation sa halip na maging sa ikatlong resilience
level ang pec ay isang espesyal na kakayahan na kailangan mong manu-manong i-on sa Qiskit dahil ang computational resources
na kinakailangan para dito ay hindi nagsasala nang maayos kumpara sa ibang mga air mitigation techniques na tinalakay natin
magsisimula ka sa pamamagitan ng pagkatuto tungkol sa ingay na nakakaapekto sa iyong circuit sa pamamagitan ng pagpapatakbo ng noise learning o noise characterization
circuits para sa bawat natatanging layer ng dalawang qubit gates na nasa iyong circuit ang mga resultang ito ay nagbibigay-daan sa iyo na ilarawan ang ingay
sa mga tuntunin ng Pauli operators kapag alam mo na ang mga noise terms na ito maaari mong baguhin ang iyong mga circuit para
epektibong may kabaligtarang pec na built-in para kanselahin ang mga noise channel na ito sa ilang paraan ang prosesong ito ay
katulad ng noise cancelling headphones gayunpaman ang paraan ng pag-undo ng ingay ay napaka-mahal na may oras na
tumatakbo nang lumalaking exponentially nang mabilis sa bilang ng mga gate kaya maaaring hindi ito ang pinakamahusay na pagpipilian para sa isang napakalaking circuit
ngayon ay narating na natin ang huling yugto ang postprocessing sa katapusan kung nagawa mo nang maayos at ginamit ang tamang error
mitigation techniques maaari mong makita ang iyong huling sagot na lumilipat tulad ng sa figure na ito dito ang isang hindi mitigated na distribution
na ipinapakita sa purple ay medyo malayo mula sa tunay na inaasahang halaga na ipinapakita dito sa linya na ito gayunpaman kapag nailapat na natin ang ating error
mitigation nakakakuha tayo ng isang mitigated distribution na ipinapakita dito sa asul na nagpe-peak nang mas malapit sa tunay na halaga ngayon
lahat ito ay may bayad at dito makikita natin na ang variance o ang lapad ng distribution ay tumaas na
karaniwang hindi iyon ang gusto mo ngunit lahat ay may bayad sa kabutihang palad maaari tayong ipaliwanag ito sa pamamagitan ng pagpapatakbo ng mas maraming
shots na nagiging sanhi ng distribution na lumiiit pabalik sa isang katanggap-tanggap na antas ng kawalan ng katiyakan kaya iyon na ang tungkol dito para sa
aralin para sa susunod na beses ay kukunin natin ang lahat ng hakbang na ito at ilalagay ang mga ito nang magkasama at magtatrabaho sa isang lugar at isang halimbawa
ng aktwal na application interest may ilang bagay na maaari kong irekomenda na gawin natin hanggang noon kung hindi mo pa nagagawa
siguraduhing i-download at i-set up ang Qiskit 1.0 maaari mo ring tingnan ang kaugnay na aralin para sa kabanatang ito at
ang nakaraang episode sa IBM Quantum learning platform at sa wakas kung mayroon kang anumang interes sa mas malalim na pag-aralan at
matuto nang higit pa tungkol sa mga teknik ng error mitigation tingnan ang isa sa maraming pinagkukunan na na-link ko sa ibaba hanggang sa susunod magkita-kita tayo
[Musika]